[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so about that new and improved taliban
how's that going so far a new and
improved taliban that's like a new and
improved kidney stone
i don't see much room for an upgrade
still their spokesman held a news
conference to say that the insurgents
would honor women's rights
of course according to the delightful
rules of sharia law that's like andrew
cuomo saying i will from now on respect
women's rights as long as they're hot
and i can still grab their asses
meanwhile taliban fighters executed a
woman for not wearing a burqa
so what's new and improved exactly they
didn't torture her first or kill her
entire family i guess that's progress so
yeah thank god we're back on the world
stage too bad our play opened and closed
on the same night but at least the u.s
ambassador to the u.n sent the barbaric
thugs a strongly worded letter we have
expressed in no uncertain terms here at
the united nations through a very
strongly worded press statement from the
security council that we expect the
taliban to respect human rights
including the rights of women and girls
we have also indicated that they have to
be respectful of humanitarian law
how did wolf keep a straight face
i've seen a game of tag taken more
seriously than this a strongly worded
letter that's like a strongly worded
game of yahtzee
yeah if there's one thing we've learned
about the taliban they really respect a
stern note with a fancy typeface
meanwhile on twitter both of their
official spokesmen have unverified
accounts which seems unfair to them hell
even kilmeade has a blue check mark
it's funny the taliban on twitter that's
like fred flintstone operating an iphone
it's like a neanderthal playing call of
duty 2.
it's like joe biden wearing pants
a regime that champions a return to the
dark ages tweets about pressers from
their smartphones i wonder who their
service provider is and does the goat
porn cost extra
does for me
i'd imagine the taliban is a little miff
that you can retweet but you can't be
head and where's the emoji for death to
america anyway you think twitter
management cares former president trump
is still banned from the platform among
other republicans but so far the taliban
remains maybe twitter's ceo jack dorsey
just likes the cut of their beards
can you tell which one is which i can't
yeah twitter allows this disinformation
to remain
when i announced our drawdown in april i
said we would be out by september our
military mission afghanistan will
conclude on august 31st
the drawdown is proceeding in a secure
and orderly way
prioritizing the safety of our troops as
they depart
yeah that didn't happen so when asked
about this contradiction in treatment
twitter said their top priority is
keeping people safe of course unless
it's afghan women and people who think
like trump if those words were any more
empty they'd be hunter biden's medicine
cabinet
and as for keeping us safe you could
have told me twitter the last thing
someone sees before chrissy teigen ruins
their lives are their names trending on
your vacuous vomit engine
if you still think that social these
social media titans have your best
interests at heart you probably think
ben jerry's is in your heart best
interest too
at least the taliban doesn't pretend to
be neutral meanwhile the media says
white house officials are troubled on
how to get everyone safely out of
afghanistan which makes sense after the
botched pull out do you trust any of
these bozos to pull anything off besides
biden's compression socks
meanwhile joe disappears for days at a
time like he's campaigning again he
hides under more lids than oscar the
grouch
he spends more time in a bunker than eva
braun
fact is you can't expect a successful
edu evacuation without a threat of
destruction if you stop us have we made
that clear
no because we're the bad guy remember
our military brass were too busy
pondering critical race theory and
diversity brochures then organizing an
orderly exit
if the real problems are white racism
how can we tell the tele taliban what to
do we lost our moral authority to a
group who has the term oppressor in
their job description if only these guys
had trump 2024 decals on their rpgs it'd
be so much easier
and so joe biden became a lame duck
presidency in record time my apologies
to ducks everywhere
but it's hard to be surprised this guy's
gotten more things wrong than brian
stelter watching jeopardy
for the great unifier he's got an
unbelievable talent of breaking things
into pieces he shouldn't be running a
country he should be demolishing
kitchens on this old house
we watch our southern border dissolve
while being told we must fix central
america's problems we see law
enforcement in tatters as crime rages we
watch our energy policy implode as gas
prices soar
but to be fair he has helped russia and
opec i'll give him that
but no wonder the media the dems and the
academic institutions all work together
to get this guy elected and boy are they
quiet now thank god they all agreed to
bury that hunter biden laptop that sto
that story is still harder to find than
a don lemon viewer
and now like an aging avocado that
looked fine on the outside this
presidency turned out to be gray and
rotten on the inside so what's next
gop senator john kennedy sums it up
it was the biggest terrorist victory
since 9 11.
and giadas who want to hurt this country
and its people all over the world are
reinvigorated today
try telling that to the white house
they'll still be saying it's domestic
terrorism we need to worry about it's
the insurrection don't forget the
insurrection yeah those were the days
when you could pretend your fellow
americans were evil when in reality it
was your incompetence all along
let's welcome tonight's guest
this vegetarian is not afraid to start a
beef box business network anchor dagon
mcdowell
this is one mat who can walk all over
you former acting u.s attorney general
matt whitaker
she's like a smoke alarm loud piercing
and sometimes you have to change the
batteries fox news contributor cat tim
and a grain silo is his coffee thermos
my massive sidekick and the nwa world
television champion
cyrus
dig and dig and dan good to see you
great to see you yeah we just did the
five yes that was a joy tittle lady it
was to watch your mouth
okay
you know what did you make of uh joe's
speech today and uh how do you feel
about taliban being on twitter
um the speech was a zero because that's
how many times he actually addressed uh
what was going on in afghanistan uh the
taliban on twitter trump is not um that
will get resolved but again i think you
talked about this but the taliban plays
by the rules the rules set by the left
right
that's their fixation i just hope
because you were talking about energy
policy i just hope that the debacle
created by joe biden in afghanistan
means that every one of his other
planned policies
to destroy the united states fails
miserably that is just a stain
for example uh just getting middle-class
americans hooked on entitlements hooked
on the government that's more power and
control for the idiots like biden
also the energy policy again we're
begging countries that hate us to pump
more oil which means that our policy
here to destroy our energy economy is
just like a recruitment effort for the
greta thundberg fan club here it's just
it's just for show
and and nothing more and but i also hope
that it means that everything that that
crinkly crypt keeper hand of joe biden
touches now carries such a stench that
even moderate democrats will be afraid
to touch it because he is toxic yeah
it's i don't know how he comes back to
that matt today he said what this killed
me by the way i'm glad you're doing the
workout i uh prescribed to you it's
working i know i'm getting bigger i'm
getting skinnier all the same time it's
fantastic and taller i wish it worked
for you yes exactly
yeah well
i can't have it all yeah i was gonna
make a joke about hair but he could
still beat me up
all right
i choose to cut it like this
good choice there was a there was an
inter there was a moment in this
interview with george stephanopoulos
where stephanos opolis asked him about
the the terrible withdrawal and he said
it was four days ago hey it wasn't four
days ago and b it shouldn't matter if it
was 14 days ago it is crazy what is
going on well when you sleep for 16
hours a day
they kind of run into each other that's
true but i mean so the first thing i
keep thinking about is how
how uninformed the president united
states appears to be yeah he's not
talking about what's actually happening
in the world he's talking about thing
you know maybe somebody needs to say hey
all these refugees from afghanistan
they're not vaccinated yeah they
would like maybe that would catch him
but but you know i just am really
concerned you know the american warrior
uh is the best equipped best trained
warfighter anywhere and we need to make
sure
that this doesn't demoralize that whole
class of people right raise their hand
and swear to give their life in defense
of the republic and i'm really concerned
how demoralizing this has been and we
need to remind them every chance we get
that their sacrifice was not for naught
that you know that they were defending
uh the principles we stand for and that
the flag you know is going to fly
forever um and that we can be trusted as
an ally some of these are really on the
ropes
we need to make sure that's not law
it's a really it's a really important
point to decouple the withdrawal from
their service because part of part of
the accomplishment of their service is
that we didn't have to think about
afghanistan for a long time i didn't
think about it i was like it was just it
became background noise precisely
because of their efforts tyrus good to
see you back with your belt are you
gonna wear are you gonna carry that belt
wherever you go until somebody takes it
so they answer it the short answer is
yeah it's going to be on my shoulders
for a while
[Laughter]
what should we be doing
i know what we shouldn't be doing and
there's one thing and this is going to
be a little friendly fire yeah
on the republican side because
joe biden's gaffes are glaring i get
that but we need to stop being democrats
where all we do is attack and blame and
we know what's bad how about getting
some solutions you know senator kenny
i'm getting real he's driving me crazy i
live in louisiana
you know when he's
he's always running his mouth do your
job get off the camera i don't need to
hear
ted cruz three snowflakes landed in
texas you jumped out the country and
blamed it on your daughter so i don't
want i don't want advice on you on how
to how to get people to leave a place or
whatever afghanistan the mid we just
don't belong there our ideologies
it's centuries of the way they are and
every time we come in we make things we
put band-aids we make things better for
a little while but as soon as we leave
they go right back to where it is and
then the bloodshed happens when
president trump pulled when we pulled uh
troops out everyone was like he's a war
criminal because we left our allies to
get slaughtered and dutted et cetera et
cetera it doesn't matter what america
does if they don't believe in what we're
doing if they don't buy into it there
wasn't a huge fight from the afghanistan
army they literally would start pointing
where the tanks and stuff are as soon as
we pulled back so this is ugly but let's
get some
solutions i want to hear some great
solutions that people can get behind and
at the same time support our troops
because yes we can bash the president
it's easy he literally every time he
talks you you got something new to make
a joke about but
the and you made a great point we're
also when we're trashing we're trashing
our troops and we need to remember that
these guys are still out there giving
their lives trying to get people home
and we need to stay on point with
solutions and supporting our troops by
the way
we uh
if you came here for solutions you were
talking to the wrong guy
anyway uh kat do you have any solutions
i i did what about what anything in
general you're next sincerely cat's
gonna break this down for me yeah i
should do a sincerely cat where i solve
the crisis in the middle but you know
what you know it is actually there's a
good point here about
uh the afghan army why would you fight
if you assume why would you fight the
people that are gonna take over because
they're gonna kill your family and kill
everybody if you fight so they're just
like well
it's a taliban you know i'm just gonna
like you know anyway and why would they
they folk anyone focus on solutions if
there's been no accountability for not
having solutions and for messing this up
lying about how bad you're messing it up
and then just saying i don't know how
that happened that's way easier and
there's no consequences for it
unfortunately
um i but i yep i think the taliban's bad
that's good good on you i don't like
them they probably don't like me either
though yeah yeah yeah well a lot of
people don't like you exactly it's like
it's like putting that you're putting
them in a large group exactly i've done
things that are horribly offensive by
like western american banners yes
so i can't imagine how they would feel
yes can i volunteer my time to support
the troops yes you can yes
when they come home yeah absolutely i
don't know how you would support them
but i'm afraid to ask
moonshine yeah hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else